[Música]
en 1953 un grupo de científicos descubre
la estructura la forma del ácido
desoxirribonucleico
el adn para muchos la mirada más
profunda y reduccionista que jamás se
había tenido de esta propiedad emergente
de la materia llamada vida
ese mismo año un mes más tarde el hombre
asciende al punto más alto del planeta
al monte everest desde allí esa persona
tuvo la visión global más grande y
alucinante que jamás se había tenido de
la naturaleza y del planeta tierra
miradas contrapuestas
quizás
complementarias sin lugar a dudas
las contradicciones son para muchos y
desde una mirada
dialéctica el motor y el combustible de
la ciencia y la tecnología a través de
ellas se puede avanzar y generar
conocimiento en áreas disciplinares
específicas yo sufrí una contradicción y
fue hace unos años les pido que imaginen
un científico joven 20 años
vestido con un jardinero pelo largo
colita un guardapolvo de mangas cortas
en un laboratorio frío
lleno de azulejos con una ventana
pequeñita donde entra la luz y las
partículas de polvo flotan en el
ambiente era la academia nacional de
medicina yo estaba enfrentado a un
microscopio para muchos también el
puente que conecta el experimento con el
investigador
el microscopio tiene distintas lentes y
uno tiene la capacidad o debería tener
la de elegir la más adecuada para hacer
la observación
del objeto de estudio de ese momento
a mí me interesaba meterme bien adentro
del experimento para entender qué es lo
que estaba pasando trabajado en cáncer y
el sistema inmunológico
pero me gustaría frenar me acá me
gustaría ir a la historia de la biología
molecular para hacer un parangón y
mencionarles donde yo me sentía parado
en este en esta imagen que les quiero
plantear imagínense dos colinas dos
montañas con un valle en el medio un río
hermoso cristalino en una de las cimas
darwin mediados del siglo 19 con sus
ojos desnudos con un catalejo tomando
apuntes y observando la naturaleza pudo
construir la teoría de la evolución a
través de la selección natural y como
biólogo me encanta decir que nada tiene
sentido si no se mira a través de los
ojos de la evolución estoy orgulloso de
haber metido este bocadillo en la charla
desde ahí comenzó un camino
reduccionista largo y no tenía la menor
idea de lo que pasaba dentro de los
organismos pero si la visión global
de la mano de mendel morgan griffith
every clock mccarthy watson creek y
rosalind franklin se logró ese camino
descendente hasta llegar a la estructura
del ácido desoxirribonucleico que es
quizás el momento en donde yo estaba
parado enfrente del microscopio no se
puede seguir bajando como dice serrat el
cantautor catalán es bueno estar en el
fondo del pozo porque de allí en
adelante en este caso sería el valle
solo cabe ir integrando así o ir
mejorando como decía él
los compañeros que yo tenía la facultad
ecólogos muy sabios por cierto nos
cargaban nos decían que los biólogos
moleculares pecábamos si es que el
término vale en esta en este espacio de
mirar las cosas demasiado adentro y
perder la visión global yo lo tomaba
como un chiste pero en realidad tenían
razón desde ese momento en lo personal y
en la historia de la biología molecular
el camino dio la vuelta a 180 grados es
decir que comenzamos a subir la segunda
colina hasta la segunda cima pero
integrando los conocimientos sin perder
lo que se había logrado en la primera
parte del siglo 20
proyectos o teorías como el dogma
central de la biología molecular los
primeros pasos en la ingeniería genética
la aparición de la biotecnología y luego
la secuenciación del genoma humano nos
hicieron llegar a la segunda cima donde
está la biología integrativa la biología
de sistemas enfrentado a darwin opuestas
posiblemente complementarias sin lugar a
dudas los profesionales que están en esa
cima y que están relacionados con el
área de interés mía que es la salud son
los médicos biólogos biotecnólogos
bioquímicos y bioinformáticos que
trabajan para integrar y entender el
funcionamiento del cuerpo humano y
también poder predecir la aparición de
enfermedades y por qué no encontrar cuál
es la droga que mejor va a funcionar
para tratar una enfermedad eso significa
que tenemos que hoy en día formar
médicos que sepan de biología molecular
en lo más profundo de esa disciplina
tenemos que formar bioinformáticos que
sepan de clínica tampoco lo que
necesitamos es lograr la interacción
entonces entre estos profesionales de
manera tal de lograr el resultado más
integrador posible y con la mayor
certeza y predicción que se pueda
esa es la biología integrativa la
biología del sistema que estamos
viviendo seguramente todos ustedes
tendrán enfrente un microscopio tal vez
no materializado como lo que conocemos
como microscopios y puede ser que sea un
pizarrón un torno una calculadora un
bloc de notas una computadora
propiamente dicha y en cada uno de esos
casos ustedes van a tener la oportunidad
de elegir la lente adecuada no tenga
miedo a elegir una lente que acerque
mucho y otra que aleje porque justamente
esas miradas son complementarias y no
contrapuestas si ustedes logran resolver
un problema utilizando esta este
acercamiento experimental no importa en
qué área del conocimiento estén
transitando yo voy a sentir que está
contradicción de casi 30 años de vida
comienza de alguna manera a empezar a
estar resuelta muchas gracias
i
[Música]